did you guys watch a lot of nature
videos oh yeah i [ __ ] love nature
documentaries i think yeah i grew up
watching like because they used to just
do like constant reruns of like every
like david attenborough documentary so i
suppose in [ __ ] uh australia oh yeah
we
love that [ __ ] go outside and you'll see
your local kangaroo fighting come on
there now now the only kangaroo club was
the one where the guy punched the
kangaroo in the face
that one was all over australian use for
like two months
always like saving what's that about
what's that like he was uh the kangaroo
was like kangaroo had the dog yeah he
had his dog in like a in a grip and like
a vice grip how does that happen i don't
know the clip literally starts with the
guy in his truck
like just calling out to the dog being
like oh no [ __ ] terry whatever the
[ __ ] his name was i remember what it was
and he jumps out and like the camera
pans over and this red kangaroo like
[ __ ] you know
[ __ ] standing like two meters
tall just has the dog in like a grip
like this and the dog's just like
help me
it has the most like help face that i've
ever seen
and he squares up mm-hmm and the
kangaroo is [ __ ] squaring up and
that's really dangerous because like you
know one kick from this red kangaroo
like in the chest that dude is dead yeah
100 right um but no this guy's like the
biggest mega chat on the planet which
just goes whack it just sucks him in the
face and the kangaroo's like what the
[ __ ]
he looks around he's like
no just jumps away
and he saves the dog but like i think as
well like the the kangaroo felt
threatened by the dog i think so like
the kangaroo also tried to like
kick the dog as well so the dog could
have died too what do kangaroos eat what
are they grass
uh are they herbivores yeah
but they're also very pretty [ __ ]
strong for herbivores but they're also
extremely territorial as well
is the is the picture i've seen of like
jacked kangaroos is that photoshop or is
that like real i could never tell if
i've seen it in memes some of them are
real and i'm sure some of them are like
overdone but like the red kangaroos
which are like the biggest burrito
kangaroos like they like on average
stand like two meters tall
[ __ ] i mean australia is like the
most interesting wildlife yeah i mean
that's because it was like a it was pan
jayed
on its own for like
hundreds of thousands of years yeah so
all these weird animals that was like
one of the first ones to like break off
yeah so it's had hundreds of thousands
of years but that's also why it's also
like super delicate and why yeah when
they introduced foreign pests
it like completely [ __ ] up australia
yeah like they have a rabbit problem you
know what do you know about this yeah
yeah
but they can't kill the rabbits you know
why why because people don't want them
to kill the rabbits but the rabbits are
literally killing everything everyone's
like oh the bunnies are so cute though
and farmers are like uh
they
they like eat everything and there's
nothing left for like the you know the
because rabbits are like insane they're
like so good at like taking everything
yeah and [ __ ] i mean like the british
yeah yeah yeah
they literally well i think it was
brought over by a british guy of course
it was because the guy wanted to hunt
rabbits in australia australia so he
brought over some rabbits i could be
incorrect on this and obviously rabbits
are like very very good at expanding
yeah and so yeah they have they have
this problem and they've been trying to
they had a they were gonna start
culling them
and getting rid of them but obviously
trying to pass a thing saying hey we're
going to murder a million plus rabbits
is that cool with everyone a lot of
people are like no rabbits are so cute
we can't get rid of rabbits
but it's like but it's like but our
wildlife is but but rabbits are cute
it's a really interesting question of
like is it you know obviously just
because it's cute
at which point do you count something as
a pest that needs control well i think
when it's actively when it's like
actively [ __ ] up the the natural
world yeah that's the problem is that
like the
delicate ecosystem that australia has
because it's so susceptible to
uh
um pests and stuff i think
the rabbit was just like went crazy and
so many of the the natural um
what does it [ __ ] up what did the
rabbits [ __ ] up well they eat everything
they take everything because they eat
all the the food that the natural like
animals are right rabbits
are only like
as from what i understand like they
are only limited by how much food
they're
yeah they they can breed and make as
many of themselves they need to it's
just is there enough food available and
they're really good at getting it as
well so like the one of those [ __ ]
tiny rats with big ears and a tail in
australia oh bilby's yeah like those
things eat [ __ ] compared to the rabbits
the rabbits like absolutely cream them
and everything
and also rabbits like rabbits eat their
own babies
do they yeah
google do they actually do they that's
metal as [ __ ]
like rabbits don't give a [ __ ] like
everyone's like oh rabbits are so cute
rabbits eat their [ __ ] babies bro
well you gonna call something cute when
it's like devouring its first born child
it's like
this one i could just make another one i
mean
sometimes yeah but it but like
the fact that that's even an option is
like nice i mean let's be honest humans
are let's let's pretend like humans
haven't done it all right we're not
great we're not if we judge the whole
species by one or two rogue rabbits
okay the one thing that doesn't make
sense to me i guess okay is okay rabbits
are [ __ ] thriving in australia
they're like beating the [ __ ] out of
australian wildlife yeah why is it not
why isn't our problem in the uk
well because you guys don't have enough
native animals well rabbit rabbits are
as far as i understand they're native to
the uk yeah so
the whole
like ecosystem in the uk had been
created right with rabbits being in it
for a very long time yeah if i'm correct
can you google this
foxes
your foxes eat the wraps yeah you need
to have the balance right and i just i'm
just finding it funny that rabbits can
survive [ __ ] australia where you look
at a spider wrong and you're [ __ ]
well i mean
like in the uk what the in the uk foxes
are like the biggest [ __ ] of the
animal kingdom
australia has a lot of species
that are like it's like the you know
you're playing on the the easy server
you know if
it's like a lot of these even though we
know australia is like one of these
super scary animals with these snakes
and stuff they have a lot of species of
animals that can only survive in
australia yeah yeah and it's very
delicate well like koalas for example
right only eat eucalyptus and a specific
type of eucalyptus that's grown in only
in australia natively yeah so that's why
you don't see koalas in the wildlife out
outside anywhere else because they
literally can't survive yeah like in any
other continent like the animal probably
wouldn't have evolved to just eat one
type of plant that is very
not popular yeah you know what i mean
you would have to adapt gonzo
yeah so
okay but in australia but like it's in
our territory now baby if you introduce
a species there's a problem like why
these
obviously people don't understand this
in like the 1900s yeah we didn't [ __ ]
know what was going on they were like
just bring my pets over and surely it'll
be fine
what i understand is the the argument of
why we shouldn't be getting rid of these
rabbits it's like oh they're so cute
meanwhile when the australian government
was like eat the kangaroos right now no
one was like but they're so cute okay
this is also a common thing with cats
cats are more often a very big past in
places people don't want to get rid of
cats because
people have pets that yeah they have
cats
if the government is like hey you at
home are you okay with us killing all of
this animal and you look down and you
see that animal staring at you that
you've loved and named and fed and you
know what i mean it's really hard and so
what you're saying is less people need
to keep rabbits as pets
i understand
what he's saying is rabbits have way too
good pr yeah yeah
so there's two [ __ ] good they're like
the
of like animals they've got it like
right you can tell them that mcdonald's
puts all the [ __ ] in their food it
doesn't [ __ ] matter people are gonna
eat it it's like i'm i understand both
sides and i i don't i i i empathize with
both i empathize with these poor like
these people who care about the natural
wildlife who are like we need to keep it
the way it was supposed to be i also
understand why that person with 10
rabbits at home might not want to have
all of the rabbit population culled yeah
i get both right
also another fun fact
while we're on fun facts about adams go
on
did you know
i love this this i i was i was watching
an episode of qri the other day are they
talking about this
do you know why for the longest time
they never gave
the giant tortoise a genome like an
official genome name
why you know
like they could they you know how every
name every animal has a greek name oh
okay right right do you know why they
never gave the giant like turtle her
name no
we they knew about this animal for a
very long time right problem was these
are the [ __ ] they can live like
300 years yeah exactly
problem was
people couldn't stop eating them they
never ever made it back oh i did hear
about this yeah because every time every
time they tried to ship the tortoises
people would just eat them yeah it would
never survive the journey because they
were too delicious
so
apparently through the because we don't
eat it anymore obviously yeah
yeah yeah because there's none left
there an endangered species now
in the writing right here's the it is
literally like the perfect storm of
unfortunate for the giant tortoise
so
apparently in the in all of the
documents left about the giant tortoise
it tastes better than any meat yeah it
tastes better than lamb it tastes better
than beef it tastes better than pork
everyone like almost unanimously agreed
who tried this meat agreed that it
tasted better than all of them right
damn i want to try it right
another unfortunate uh evolutional uh
part of the giant tortoise is that it
also ah this is just so sad
it evolved so that it could store up to
like one gallon or one liter of water i
don't remember which one it was yeah
yeah inside of its body almost perfectly
like a sack so when you would eat it as
a human there was almost perfectly this
one liter capsule so basically it came
with a drink it came with a with a it's
like a meal imagine it you've just had
this you know you're you're living it's
just a survival pack yeah at the end of
the day you're living at the time where
beer
was drank more than water yeah yeah yeah
water was hard
it was it was hard to get a hold of in
in certain places so you had this animal
that tasted amazing
that was this perfect kind of like it
could store very easily it was very easy
to eat
or a lot of the meat was edible in it as
well and it had this one gallon sack of
water that you could just drink so
sailors would when they would take them
back they were like well [ __ ] we're
going to eat it yeah
because not only was it delicious and
amazing they also had a free gallon of
water they could drink so it never made
it wait so does it have a genome now it
did it did after after many many years
it finally got one but food but it never
it never survived the journey back to
like the uk or something yeah so they
could never classify it yeah yeah
that's just so good
that's really [ __ ] up but that's
hilarious that's just like can you
imagine it just on the boat and you're
like [ __ ]
i just wanna i i couldn't
imagine the science just waiting
all right i wanna see this animal so i
can figure it out like what do you mean
you ate it like that on the pork back
they're like we're going to bring back
10.
we're going to eat 9.
we're going to let one go back all right
we all agree one can go back we only
need one to name it
one week left on the ship and they're
like
[ __ ]
dude
remember that flambe giant tortoise we
had dude oh that's looking kind of
delicious right now i'm getting real
parched
just makes me wonder how good most of it
must have tasted yeah they must have
been amazing they just come back to port
they're like
we brought ten bag we got one how many
shells we gotta have one
the way they wrote about it was that it
was so delicious that like it sounded
like they genuinely just like couldn't
resist eating it yeah but like imagine
it's that delicious real like
boys defense just going for like a quick
voyage to the the
the islands to go and get some more more
giant tortoises and they just keep
eating it every time
i'd like to think it was that good they
would go back to go and get more me and
the boys
oh dude
yeah it's an endangered species now
right
it's like
oh wait i thought it was just indeed we
[ __ ] up okay okay
but so it's kind of like the dodo as
well right yeah
but like i would rather okay i'm not i'm
not i don't want us to extinct any
animal right but i would rather as
extinct animal because it's too damn
delicious not that it's that we wanted
its horn or something that feels so
wasteful if we're like dude we made a an
amazing stew out of the giant tortoise
part of me is like that's [ __ ] up okay
at least you used which one do you think
like natural selection just should just
take its course right right
okay i'm just going to say
like it's your fault for being born this
delicious i don't know i don't know i
mean he's got a point he's got a point
if
if why the [ __ ]
this animal just was so unfortunate that
it evolved to be the perfect
like like food for humans to eat you
[ __ ] up in some way
in evolution by being super delicious
right and having
they just didn't survive obviously again
every part of the tour choice was also
edible yeah apparently was also
delicious in soups and stuff it was
every single part of this [ __ ] was
delicious this tortoise had evolved
somehow to be so goddamn delicious
i don't get it and i'm angry that i'm
never going to chill yeah
yeah i'm angry that i'm going to try it
now as well so i mean i'm more angry
that it's extinct because i can't right
now
it's [ __ ] feelings
or something yeah we're a month later we
can't care about nature or something all
that [ __ ] but you know
the delicious animal i mean we've talked
about eating possible dinosaurs and all
the dinosaurs we might not possibly be
able to eat you know like where's the
jurassic park episode where they bring
back a extinct animal so they can just
like serve it as a delicacy right that's
all i'm saying
we bought this like the signs like we
brought back the t-rex yeah because we
heard flambeing this [ __ ]
so yeah that's what jurassic park would
actually be it wouldn't be a it would be
a restaurant it wouldn't be a
thing
it wouldn't be a theme park it would be
like come on come on if you bring back
an extinct animals there's gonna be that
one [ __ ] who's like
me i'm gonna be there
how do they taste come on there's got it
there's definitely gonna be a dinosaur
restaurant somewhere in the world of
course you know i mean it's the you know
the turtle it's unfortunate that it was
perfectly evolved to be yeah
to be eaten i mean it was on the wall i
mean
there are some animals where i'm just
like without humans you'd be [ __ ]
you'd be on your last legs i mean
we saved you you should be you're
grateful
how did how did uh how did pandas become
china's like national animal right
because is it isn't it like pandas isn't
it like they have to [ __ ] they do not
[ __ ] yeah they just refuse to [ __ ]
have offspring and [ __ ] and i'm just
like if you have an animal that just
like does anything that is possibly
could to willingly not [ __ ] breed
like at which point you were just like
maybe they just don't want us they exist
just like we just want to die
here's the problem with us as humans
when i think it comes to us with extinct
animals yeah the amount of shits we give
about saving an animal is inherently
tied to how cute it is that is that is
such a i i i refuse to believe any other
explanation
do you if you told us oh we have to save
this one species of uh
flounder people would be like we could
live without a flashlight but it's
delicious yeah yeah yeah
there's two things people care about is
it delicious
and is it cute right like if if a panda
wasn't as cute as it is no would we care
we are so [ __ ] biased all of the
animals we want to save are either cool
as [ __ ] or cute as [ __ ] that is true
think about it think of an animal top
the head that that people are trying to
help like you see campaigns about and
stuff that where the animal isn't cute
or cool i mean i don't know how like i
know
it's like the most endangered species i
know are like pandas
name extinct animals
cool cool yeah cool um i mean it's
certainly an animal with good pr right
that's it yeah but but to get good pr
you need to be cute right yeah cute all
like bad ass like if the species of
snake snake was dying out yeah those
snake people online would
make people
you know you know who i'm talking about
but
most people wouldn't give a [ __ ] let's
be honest like you're not gonna see the
like the fundraisers about it i'm just
being honest like that's how we are
we're so [ __ ] biased as humans yeah
we love to be like oh yeah save all the
animals except the ugly ones [ __ ] them
they can die unless they're like unless
they're like exceptionally ugly like the
blob fish where it just becomes a meme
though like now we got to save it now
look at this
it's fugly
now it's like it's so ugly it's cute
yeah now i'm [ __ ] cheering for it
because it's the [ __ ] underdog now
look at it i know no one's gonna cheer
for that
we need to save the the tooth fish and
it's just a fish that is just like
literally razor blades and like no eyes
or face you're like well no one gives a
[ __ ] if it dies i mean i i don't get me
wrong i'm sure the scientists who spend
their life researching this stuff will
be very sad but the general population
doesn't care yeah let's not pretend like
we do
yeah we don't we don't no we don't we
don't we only care when it's already
happened yeah yeah i guess so i mean i
mean like i mean like animals have been
animals have been going extinct for the
entire history of nature itself i'm not
saying we should just let them go
extinct no no no i'm not i'm not saying
that i'm saying like okay
i feel like this should be like i feel
like we should try to preserve nature as
much as we can
um but you know
we're not going to be like weak mindset
i want to be the board meeting
what is this
i think we should get rid of all the
players
i mean like if humans have had like a
direct effect on making this animal
these things i think yeah we should we
should take responsibility and be like
okay yeah we kind of [ __ ] up their
entire environment their entire habitat
yeah let's let's let's try not to do
that again unless they're delicious of
course you think rabbits have this this
meaning
should we uh stop [ __ ] i actually
taking over a lot of things
enjoying it too much
consume consume [ __ ] consume